welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's Friday so
it's time for the mando everywhere I go
I make the gang go with the fourth
episode of Star Wars the Mandalorian now
hitting Disney Plus it's time to go back
to a long time ago in a galaxy far far
away throughout this video we'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the latest episode its
overall plot the Easter eggs and our
theories on what could be happening in
the future there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch episode 4 yet and don't want to
know what happens then I highly suggest
that you turn off now make sure you
subscribe to the channel for breakdowns
like this every day and weekly coverage
on the mandalorian without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of the mandalorian okay so
episode 4 opens on the planet of Sauron
namely a small fishing village that we
see in the middle of a raid from Cantu
nians this location becomes the main
staying point of the episode and this
introduction sort of place into the
overall arc of this week's entry we do
see for a split second in the episode
that Sauron has two moons which may echo
the two suns of Tatooine and this is a
nice little Easter Egg for fans of the
force during the raid we see a character
known as oh Mira and her daughter winter
hiding out much in the same way that
mano had to hide out as a child though
the settings are different there are
still similarities and this lets us know
that no matter what things suck in the
galaxy the collapse of the Empire has
sort of destabilized everything and we
need order order 66 hashtag make the
galaxy great again now for me this is a
beautiful introduction and it really
shows how much effort Disney are putting
into their productions throughout those
metaphors for the Battle of Endor with
an organic natural location being taken
over by cold hard and imperialistic
figures we jump to the races crest which
is sort become a kindergarten for baby
Yoda who gets cuter and cuter by the
minute touching things and getting told
off by his newly adopted dad Oh
and oh this scene is adorable and you
really get the care that he has over the
creature which is what the backbone of
the series really is your little womp
rat mando picks up Zorgon and decides
that after last week's big ordeal that
they need to hide out from bounty
hunters and this backwater planet is the
perfect place to pick the famous last
words are no one's gonna find us here
and they land on sorg in which mando
says he will scout out by himself
you can't leave a little baby out of
Hein though and he quickly joined sim on
this adventure now I love how they are
slowly starting to build their
relationship and this opener for the
episode really flashes out their
attachment with one another it's amazing
that the creative team have managed to
convey such emotion and attachment
between what is basically a guy whose
face we can't see and a puppet there's
not all that much dialogue between the
two but watching dinner on say oh what
the hell come on is a moment that really
solidifies their relationship with one
another when exploring the settlement we
get our first introduction to Korra Joon
who we learn is an ex shock trooper that
was part of the Rebel Alliance we also
see a loft cat which hisses a baby Yoda
and these creatures were big mainstays
in rebels now all of the people who were
complaining that the Mandalorian didn't
have any female characters can shut the
hell up now and go and find something
else completely pointless to complain
about because Korra is a badass and
early on she goes head-to-head with
mando showing that she's a clear match
for the character I love the scene where
he follows her out using detective
vision to track her footprints and just
as he thinks he's closing the net she
pops up with a nice surprise mando may
be able to take a blaster bolt to the
head without flinching but one of Kara's
punches puts him out faster than Disney
managed to get baby older toys out get
it cuz cuz that didn't get them out very
fast just as it looks like the two are
about to shoot one another baby Yoda
pops up instantly calming the situation
and subtly saying hello to his new mom
and dad Korra divulges that since the
events of Return of the Jedi that the
rebels have been hunting down the
Imperial warlords and that she was a
member of the assassination team that
tracked them down this is a very clear
metaphor on the second world war when
Jewish forces were tracked down
surviving members of the Reich that had
went into hiding in countries like
Brazil and Argentina and this
made car a call to the galaxy cora has a
very small Rebel Alliance Tatiana cheek
that we catch glimpses up throughout the
episode and this lets you know just how
loyal she was to the group she ended up
going into early retirement finding a
home on Sauron and she was initially
wary about boy mando because she
believed that he was a bounty hunter for
imperial forces that were out for
revenge all I can say is thank God for
baby Yoda I don't just mean in the show
I mean thank God cuz Star Wars was
looking dead til it showed up I'm still
using it as a pronoun for baby Yoda
because we don't know if it's a boy or
girl yet however I have seen some people
say that it is in fact a girl in the
script though I've been unable to verify
this fully plot twist of the century
though yeah baby Yoda could be a girl
guess those people who said that there's
no females in the Mandalorian a feeling
priests stupid right now aren't they I
know it's you dislike in the video right
now anyway after this exposition dump
Cara says that mando and baby Yoda have
to move on because otherwise it will
draw attention to her hiding place and
the two look like they're gonna be back
on the road again until two people from
the village recruit the Mandalorian to
protect their home initially he's put
off by the idea but quickly man--not
realizes just how good of a hiding place
this could be for the characters with
the help of Cara they go to the village
and we rejoin winter and other kids who
fall head-over-heels with baby Yoda this
would have been the perfect advert for
kids Christmas presents but dizzy didn't
get the toys out in time so yeah well
done guys great job now throughout the
episode I really got flashes of the
classic film Seven Samurai and a lot of
the atmosphere throughout this entry I
think apes that the way the huts were
designed had an almost ancient Japanese
feeling to them and if you're gonna
steal you might as well steal from the
best right let me know if you disagree
or agree with me in the comments but
personally I saw a lot of similarities
and maybe being Captain Obvious right
now but yeah that that's what I picked
up from this episode Amira sparks up a
conversation with manda at one point in
the episode as she notices that he
doesn't remove his helmet at all even
when others are eating around him Mandel
confirms that he hasn't removed his
helmet in front of anyone since he was a
child and I bet it smells like Banda
Pudu in there anyway this is the
mandalorian way as we saw in episode 3
and no initially
was stated that the character would
never take it off throughout the entire
series we do see him remove it in this
episode though we don't see his face he
does take it off in order to eat and
this scene echoes the moment in the
Empire Strikes Back
where Vader removes his helmet and we
get a glimpse at the character from
behind in Star Wars helmets almost used
as a way to separate the humanity of the
character from what's really going on
and the fact that man who removes his
helmet at one point right next to a
window could show that he is opening up
to the galaxy he talks a lot more in
this episode and as far as character
development goes it's hard to really
fault how far he's come
later on he mentions that once you take
the helmet off you can't really put it
back on again and it's highlights that
when you open up that it's difficult to
close yourself off the helmet really
acts as a wall for the character
throughout the episode with a Mira
desperately trying to remove it because
she knows that if she does the two will
finally have a connection even if man no
rebuffs this and leaves it on for the
finale of the episode to show that he's
a man of the code putting his duties
above all else we know that man oh did
at one point live life helmet free so
that to me suggests that the fan theory
that he was found and rescued by the
Mandalorians during the Great Purge has
a lot of weight to it some lip service
paid to this and we did see last time
that the character came paced a gun with
a super battle droid and it is possible
that during this moment Mandalorians
came to the rescue and he ended up
joining them there's also theories that
he was saved by a Jedi most likely Yoda
and this is why he gained such an
attachment to the young critter that he
now has as a best friend though this
episode doesn't offer up any answers in
terms of what's really happened I am
leaning more towards the first theory
now as mono did not have any awareness
of the force and thus he probably didn't
know about the Jedi which would have
been the case during the original
trilogy as they were all but extinct
when out scouting Korra and mono
discover the tracks of an 80s Dee or as
we used to call them back in the day
chicken walkers this highlights that
since the fall of the Empire a lot of
their materials have become scavenged
and hoarded by criminals moser namely
the group of clan - nian Raiders Korra
and my manma mando Oh
so I need to stop calling people my man
returned to a mirror and tell them that
they need to leave but they refused to
and in order for them to serve
what's going to come we're gonna need a
montage after everyone gets trained up
they laid the plan out whether you use a
ditch to trap the chicken Walker sorry a
TST and during this the villages will
fight back against the Raiders it's an
awesome action scene and I love this sob
Mad Max tone that the show has slowly
evolved into even the ending echos that
series of a man on the road going from
location to location helping people and
this big fight in the second half of the
episode really doesn't disappoint mando
and chorus Niek into the writers camp
and blow up their favorite tent which
lulls them into activating the a TST
complete with evil-looking red eyes and
it follows them back to the farm there
was a feeling here of war of the worlds
for me and the tree line shuffling about
as the huge machine lurched forward this
episode definitely showcases how
intimidating 80's teas are and if you
found them laughable after they got
beaten so badly by the Ewoks then this
will definitely return them as one of
the coolest crafts and Star Wars
unfortunately for the two the trap
doesn't work right away and the Walker
doesn't walk her way into the trap
that's got to be one of the worst puns
I've ever done it fires from a distance
while it's Raiders rushed the group
eventually the 80s D does fall into the
trap after Cora rushes at it with a
rifle and din jarring blows it up by
throwing a bomb into the cockpit Raiders
retreat and it looks like the villagers
have won the battle is over and they
just managed to get through it by the
skin of their teeth if only if only
they'd had someone extremely strong with
the force I could have destroyed that
Walker in a second now speaking of baby
Yoda mono has a tough decision to make
he can either return back to life on the
road after the ruckus he has caused or
he can retire and live in peace he
doesn't want to remain but he realizes
that this would be an amazing place for
baby Yoda to grow and have a normal
childhood out in the forest of bounty
hunters track down the character and a
Mira tries to get him to finally remove
his helmet accepting his place in the
village he refuses and this actually
saves his life as he unknowingly is
being watched by the hunter who
potentially has a sniper shot for the
character the hunter aims for baby Yoda
and he shot last second by Korra which
is when it's revealed that the hunter
has been tracking the case
though man Oh destroys this locator we
know that there will be others and Cora
and man know part ways until their paths
cross again with the lone wolf and his
pup heading out into the galaxy ending
the episode now going forward
man no basically only has two choices
you can either keep running hoping to
evade the long arm of both the Empire
and the bounty hunters or you can take
them head-on in order to stop them
tracking him it looks like the character
actually goes with the former over the
latter with a synopsis for episode 5
saying the Mandalorian helps a rookie
bounty hunter who is in over his head
this could be someone who is trying to
track him down that simply can't match
up with the bounty hunter so he decides
to help him out and build his own
network rather than constantly having to
look over his shoulder this is kind of
backed up by the synopsis for episode 6
which reads the Mandalorian joins a crew
of mercenaries on a dangerous mission
even though it may not be intentional it
does look like our characters a building
of group that they can at least rely on
should things with the Empire heat up
which no doubt they will as everyone
including my grandma wants a baby Yoda
I'm surprised that we didn't get any
more backstory this episode but I do
have a feeling that sooner rather than
later
we will get an episode that centers
heavily on mandos past and answers more
questions about the character overall I
had a great time with this week's entry
and it feels like another solid episode
and a show that is slowly becoming one
of the best Star Wars properties and yes
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the Mandalorian episode 4 as
well as what your theories for the
future are you enjoyed the video then
please give it a thumbs up and make sure
you check out our full breakdown of the
Mandalorian so far which would be linked
at the end you've gone over the whole
series episode by episode so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to come
chat to me after the video that makes
you follow me on twitter at definition
whitey will head over to my discord
server which should be linked in the
description below we drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon also giving
away a free copy of the marble phase 3
part 2 boxer on blu-ray which
Taine's black panther infinity war and
game captain table more and all you have
to do to be in with a chance of winning
is like the video make sure that you
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the mandalorian in the
comment section below but when it's
gonna be chosen on the 15th of december
and the set will be shipped out from the
enter against the prize so best of luck
to everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]